were you getting paid to intern
absolutely not okay cool i just want to
make sure because there's this thing
going around on twitter
about uh unpaid internships and i'm like
a unpaid internship literally changed my
life mine too
and i and i did it for two years for
free i did it for 14 months
fresh out of high school with a newborn
baby i was trapping at the swap meet
selling bootleg cds on the weekend
and working for free money through
friday i feel like the
entire generation that we're a part of
like that we see coming up now
they don't even know what this like yeah
it's an entitled
is this entitlement thing with these
with these guys with these young kids
man it's instant gratification nobody
wants to work for nothing anymore
everybody wants to be rich as the person
that put them on immediately is crazy
another thing too is like i've saw
people on twitter like man i interned
here for
for a year and nothing happened after it
was like well cause obviously you ain't
had it bro like
if you if you if you were that if you
were that dope and you were putting in
the work you need like it's just gonna
work
like i literally got to the um office
before my boss didn't left after him
every day
me too man like i wanted to make sure he
knew that
i wanted this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that's
how i was a radio like
even when i started to get paid i would
be at the radio station doing the
morning show for free
from like four in the morning until
about 11 a.m yeah
then i'd go do a street hit which is
when i finally started to get paid so
i'd be doing that [ __ ] all day
check this out then i would do my
overnight so i would literally go home
and sleep for like four hours i'd be at
the radio station
you know 18 hours out the day just just
grinding i just feel like
that's important for people to
understand like this [ __ ] ain't like
like we we really work to get where we
at bro and i think you know when you put
that
that level of hard work ethic into you
know the structure
of your daily life like it shows why you
know people like us are where we're at
today
you know what i'm saying because we know
what it takes to get there